I've been to Asama, but someday I'll be able to leave the forest and live a normal life.It's
like Juice and everyone in the village got along well
Just like Subaru told me he liked me
Mother and Juice stood side by side  It's a world I should have been able to walk in. I'm sure
there will be ice sculptures of the villagers there.
Hurry up, and if you'll forgive me, I'll introduce you to the world, so
there's no need to live in hiding anymore.
I told my mother upstairs so that she could hear
me I'm happy in the world she loved I
see,
I understand
That's right, no,
these 4 series are over
How self-righteous conclusions are There's no difference in the settlement of the past Use your
mother's sacrifice as an excuse to be prepared,
at best you should stick to your selfish wishes You can do
whatever you want, Echidna
You've gotten used to it, but there
are at most two more trials left I'd like to put my hopes into the party, but I'm sure you
'll have a scene with an owner.
I don't really get along with you, who's
defiant.